episode 206 was the start of a very
interesting emotional arc for me i think
that oftentimes african-american women
in corporate environments are tokenized
and they are taken advantage of because
they need help to get up the ladder i
can see
you're obviously hurting
can you see that chip
i think karen pittman portrays her with
such magnificence that you can see the
pain you can see the complexity and you
can see her struggle i trust you will do
the right thing but you won't let your
personal involvement cloud your judgment
during this time there was an undeniable
new
anti-asian sentiment that was happening
it was uncomfortable to talk about but i
was grateful that we were able to
incorporate it and talk about it with a
level of care and dexterity in terms of
how we were going to present this
can you give me pictures or not
one of the most interesting things that
the show attempts to do is wrestle with
the idea of just how hard it is to be an
adult in the world where the foundations
are shifting all the time i love corey's
moral ambiguity he does some of the most
incredible selfless things he does some
of the most horrible things and he does
them with equal enthusiasm he's a
strategist and i think when his strategy
doesn't work he pivots quickly someone
being outed against their will this is
not about being outed when laura leaves
bradley's dressing room she turns around
and says to her and you're right it's
wrong what happened the first time i
said the line i thought i'm going to cry
and i don't want to cry here it's not my
scene this is her scene but i realized
when i actually verbalized those lines
it's just the worst feeling you could
ever have mom's been calling she's
embarrassed
i think there are a lot of people who
are very constrained by their upbringing
i see bradley growing in this moment and
slowly pulling herself away from a
family that tried to define her with
very narrow terms i have a lot of
clarity right now in this season there's
a lot of self-examination who are they
what matters and we question that a lot
through our characters
you